alors tous en jacques goldman
jean-jacques comment vous comportez vous
avec les médias
vous estimez que la télévision est une
chose importante ou à ce que c'est
d'abord la radio qui est le vecteur le
plus important est ce que la télévision
soit que c'est ce que vous pensez
d'abord une résultante mais c'est
d'abord la radio qui fait connaître une
chanson à la descendre la chanson dans
la rue mais d'abord je me comporte pas
avec les médias c'est les médias qui se
comporte avec moi ce qui est très
nouveau
alors moi je fais les chansons puis je
vois toute espèce de monde qui s'agite
autour qui est bizarre je crois qu'au
début il ya la radio parce qu'une
chanson elle a pas besoin tellement de
vecteurs c'est à dire les gens
l'écoutent ils n'ont pas besoin d'une
notice d'emploi d'une notice explicative
pour savoir si ça va leur plaire ou pas
donc je pense que le vecteur principal
d'une chanson là où l'entend c'est la
radio ensuite la télévision pour mettre
une image dessus comment vous voyez dans
quatre ou cinq ans comment vous allez
négocier ce virage car vous êtes
maintenant une vedette et je sais que
vous êtes très prudent à l'égard de tout
ce qui vous arrive et vous essayer
d'être le plus lucide possible car ce
qui vous arrive là bon vous le
souhaitiez
mais vous ne souhaitez pas que ça ça
devienne trop important que ça change
trop votre vie or vous le vouliez ou non
ça va changer votre vie celle-là déjà
changé enfin moi je pense qu'il faut
revenir à la chose principale qui est la
chanson on fait des chansons parce qu'on
vit des choses
le jour on vit plus des choses ont fait
plus de chansons parce que on a plus de
sujet parce qu'on n'a pas vécu des
choses intéressantes donc le piège c'est
de vivre la vie de chanteur qui est
quand même une des plus bête du monde
on vous appelle le taxi ou vous êtes
invités au restaurant etc
et à partir du moment où il se passe
plus rien et où on vit pas des choses
réelles et authentique
là je crois qu'on est cuit alors le
danger je crois que c'est ça surtout on
va retrouver jean jacques tout à l'heure